can we talk about
the
recent invasion of ukraine so you wrote
on
facebook a pretty eloquent analysis
i i think on
march 3rd
let me just read a small section of that
just to give context and maybe we can
talk a little bit more about both russia
and the man putin
he wrote although the united states has
many wars of aggression on its
conscience it doesn't justify mr putin's
aggression in ukraine
a dozen wrongs don't make a right
russia was wrong to invade it has made
too many mistakes one underestimating
ukraine resistance
two overestimating the military ability
to achieve its objective
three underestimating europe's reaction
especially germany
upping its military contribution to nato
which they've resisted for some 20 years
even switzerland has joined the cause
russia will be more isolated than ever
from the west
4. underestimating the enhanced power of
nato which will now put more pressure on
russia's borders five probably putting
ukraine into nato
six underestimating the damage to its
own economy and certainly creating more
internal resistance in russia
seven creating a major readjustment of
power in its oligarch class
eight putting cluster and vacuum bombs
into play
nine
and underestimating the power of social
media worldwide and you go on
for a while giving a much broader
picture
of the history and the geopolitics of
all of this so now
a little bit later
two months later
um what are your thoughts about the
invasion
of ukraine well it's very hard to
be honest in this regard because the
the west
the west has brought down a curtain here
and anyone who
questions uh
the invasion of ukraine and
its consequences is is
is an enemy of the people
it's it's become so difficult we i've
never seen in my lifetime ever
such a
wall of
propaganda as i've seen
in the west
and that includes france too because i
was there recently in england england is
of course
really
uh vociferous
it's it's it's shocking to me how
quickly europe moved in this direction
that includes germany i have german
friends who expressed to me their shock
over ukraine i have italian friends same
thing and italy of course has been the
perhaps the most
understanding and compassionate of
countries
so it's it's quite evident that there's
a united uh
and this attests the power of the united
states and of course you have finland
and
finland which has
generally been reasonable jumping and
talking about joining nato and sweden
too
generally there's been some more
restraint in the in the way in europe
that's what surprised me the most europe
how quickly they fell
into this nato basket
which is very dangerous for europe very
dangerous this goes back to my idea what
i was saying earlier about sovereignty
these countries have
don't really give me a sense that they
have sovereignty over their own
countries
they don't feel
european nations
i'm obviously intuition here is working
i just don't feel
that they have freedom
to say what they really think and
they're scared to say it
when
the united states invaded iraq in 2003
i remember with great ha in a sense
satisfaction that at least
france uh shirak who i had not really
known much about stood up and said the
united states were not going to join you
in this expedition basically into
madness
schroeder and germany same thing
of course putin condemned the
invasion and kupun had been an ally of
the united states since 9 11 if you
remember correctly yes and had called
bush and they were getting along so even
putin said i won't go no don't go into
iraq this is
this is not the solution he he didn't
oppose afghanistan but he opposed iraq
so
sharach
and schroeder stood for the old europe
i'm i remember de gaulle
charles de gaulle he was independent of
the united states charles de gaulle
pulled france out of nato because he saw
the dangers of nato which is to say you
have to fight an american war
when they say and they put nuclear
weapons on your territory in england and
france and uh italy and uh germany and
when they do that
you're you're hitched to this superpower
and you have no say in what they're
going to do if they declare war from
that and they use your territory you're
going to be involved in a major conflict
i'm talking about sovereignty where is
that sovereignty they don't have it
and that has influenced their mindset
for years now
since 1940s since uh well de gaulle was
the 60s
he was he actually reversed the whole
flow and he was
it was i think it was uh sarkozy who put
the france back into nato
and uh now it's
macro i i hope because he was talking to
putin would at least
have an independent viewpoint that could
be helpful here but he so he rolled it
up
he may have told putin something else
but within days he had rolled it up and
gone along with the united states
position
which was enforced by the united states
in a very fierce way
the propaganda as i say i don't know how
much time you spent in america but
it was vicious and everything was
anti-russian russia were killing all
these people were uh shooting uh down uh
uh civilians
although there was no proof of it there
was just these are the accidents of war
but all of a sudden there was a campaign
of criminality and they were talking
about bringing putin into war crime
trial well why didn't they talk like
that when iraq was going on and bush was
killing far more people
or for that matter why were they not
talking about the the killings in
donbass and lugansk
during that
2014 to
2022 period that is what is it's a crime
there were so many people that were
killed
many of them innocent many of them in it
so what would be the way for vladimir
putin
to
uh stop the killing in dambass
without the invasion of ukraine yeah
that's a very good question and i've
asked that several times and i don't
have the i have not talked to him since
about two years now uh
it's a very good question what's the
mistakes
what the human mistakes and the
leadership mistakes means a very good
question you see what the american press
has not said and the western press has
not said is that on february 24 was it
that was on that day what they invaded
the day before if you check the logs of
the uh european organization that was
you supervising uh the was in the field
in ukraine
these are
neutral observers they were seeing heavy
heavier and heavier artillery fire going
into uh
into donbass
from the ukrainian side
so they had apparently ukraine had 110
000 troops on the border they were about
to invade donbass that was the plan
that's what i think
russia as a as a because of the buildup
on the border of donbass brought 130
they say 130 000 troops to the area uh
near
donbass right so you have buildup of
forces on both sides but you wouldn't
know that from reading the press in the
west you would be you'd believe that the
russians suddenly put all these men into
into the situation within with the idea
of invading ukraine not only donbass but
invading all of ukraine and getting rid
of the uh decapitating the government
there
which is all assumption we don't know
what they would intend it to do but you
at the time is that a lot of people
thought that the
all the talk of the invasion
russian invasion of ukraine it's just
propaganda it's never it's not going to
happen it's very well
i think many of us thought that the
united states is building this up into
an invasion in other words that's that
is the nature of false flag operations
when you you create this propaganda they
are going to invade they are going to
invade and then
when they invaded the united states was
completely ready and all their allies
were completely ready for the invasion
correct so why did putin do that he fell
into this theoretically into this trap
set by the united states that
here you're telling all your allies
across the board they're going to invade
but you
why do you think he did it
so here is it madness or is it no it's
not a strategic calculation perhaps
this one i cannot answer you faithfully
because
first of all we don't know what he was
told if he was indeed getting the right
intelligence estimates
from what i said earlier on that art and
that
in that essay i wrote
you would think
he was not well informed perhaps about
the degree
of
cooperation he would get from the russia
the ukrainian russians in in in in
ukraine i
that would be one factor that he wasn't
he didn't assess the
operation correctly remember this mr
putin has had
this cancer
and he's i think he's licked it but he's
also been isolated because of covid
and some people would argue that the
isolation from
normal activity which he was he was
meeting people face to face but all of a
sudden he was meeting people across the
table uh a hundred yards away or
whatever 10 yards away it was very hard
to perhaps he lost touch uh with contact
with people so it's not just power it's
the very simple fact that you're just i
say i'm speculating i don't know i see
that and i also
perhaps he thought in his mind that
there would be a
a faster resolution that the ukrainian
because the evidence had been that the
ukrainian uh russians
the ukrainian army had folded so many
times in the
and that they were only backed up and
they were stiffened by the resistance of
the nazi uh or nazi-oriented as
off-battalions that was a factor of
course and that is a big factor for the
russians because these people are very
tough they rush see
what people don't understand is that
ukraine since 20 2014 has been a terror
state
they've been run you know any time a
ukrainian has expressed any
uh any uh understanding of a russian of
the russian ukrainian position they've
been threatened by the state from 2014
to 2022 there's been a set of hideous
murders that people don't even know
about in the west journalists
people who speak out liberals
people who uh i i interviewed victor
medvedev who they make out to be some
kind of horrible person but medvedev was
this was very important figure in the
administration of kushma the first uh
ukrainian prime minister in the 1990s
and he did a great job on the economy he
was very thoughtful man if you'll see my
interview it's called ukraine revealed
he's very thoughtful about the future of
ukraine he doesn't want to go back and
join russia he wants it to be an
independent country ukraine is
independent and he wants it to be a
functioning economic democracy more or
less a democracy if you can get that but
between
that exists in a neutral state in
neutral state which ukraine used to be
before 2014 it was neutral from 1991 to
2014 neutral very important
under
poroshenko it just immediately went into
an anti-soviet cold war position
as an ally of the united states
and uh
my point was that
it was a very dangerous place in ukraine
i your people were being killed
death squads were out there
medvedev they stripped him of his
television stations very suddenly this
is zolensky the new president said he
kazuluski was elected on a peace
platform remember that he was 70 percent
of the country was for him to make peace
with russia he did he ever have even
tried to make peace with russia did he
attend any of the minsk two
agreements did he did he visit did he
pay any attention to putin did he go to
russia no not at all the moment he got
into office i'm convinced that the
the uh
the uh militant
uh the militant sector of the right
sector parties of the uh ukraine let him
know that you will not make a deal with
russia
there'll be no concessions to russia
this is very dangerous this is where
this attitude that's very very hostile
to russia has hurt us the whole world is
being hurt by this and no no one calls
them out
no one calls them out zelensky backed
off
from his platform as a running for
president and as president has been
ineffective
did nothing to promote on the contrary
went the other way and seemed to support
the uh the ukrainian aggression
well he found his support in this war
you've revealed through your work some
of the most honest and dark aspects of
war
nevertheless this is a war and there's a
humanitarian crisis
millions of people as uh
refugees escaping ukraine what do you
think about the human cost of this war
initiated by it's horrible whoever
just as you write
whatever the context whatever nato
whatever pressure
as you wrote
russia was wrong to invade
let's get back to the original question
you said what was he thinking at that
time we never answered that yeah now
by the way uh you know
among those people who are
who have been
ruined by this war you have to include
the fort 2014 to 2022 yes ukrainian
russians 14 000
uh
were killed not necessarily by uh
some of them by maybe accident this and
that but certainly a large number of
that is is responsible to the ukrainian
military and the uh the nazi-related
battalions who have done a good job of
death squatting that whole area and
remember i did a film about salvador i
know a little bit about death squads and
how they work and i know about
paramilitaries because in south america
they're all over the place america
supports hates venezuela goes on about
venezuela but they do they tell you
anything about colombia it's next door
neighbor colombia for years has been
plagued by paramilitaries that are
right-wing and the united states has
said nothing about them except
occasionally there's a newspaper report
now so this is a
this support of death squads by the
united states is all over the world it's
not just in south america and central
america where we see
plenty of evidence of it
it's here too and this is what's
horrible about this whole thing this
hypocrisy of america that they can
support such evil such evil now going
back to your
larger question about
uh yes it's a terrible refugee disaster
but again we have to get the numbers
let's get the numbers and get evidence
because
i i would ask you i'm not sure at this
point whether more civilians were killed
before 2022 in
donbass then have been killed in this
latest so we can't talk about this
without we can't talk about the invasion
ukraine without considering the full war
between russia and ukraine since 2014.
that's correct absolutely and
take the toll on both sides and you
might be surprised by the result
uh i think the russian military of
course i'm not there and i'm not this
could be this is speculation the russian
military has slowed down and part of
that reason is not to keep the civilian
corridors open and i think the ukrainian
military has made it more difficult on
purpose especially some of these
battalions that are death squad
battalions have gone out of their way to
keep the civilians locked into these
cities in danger because it's in their
interest to do so
so there's no reason why ukrainian
military who have killed ukrainian
civilians for years would change their
policies
they would have no compunctions about
wiping out for example people with white
armbands in buka
okay
as to what putin was thinking at the
time
i
i wondered this and i still do i said
okay so putin can say
one let's say uh the ukrainian
government wants to now invade donbass
this is on february 23 and they have
artillery they're peppery in the whole
place they're going to go in and they're
going to get don bass back
what do you do
and you you have russian uh separatists
who are russian ukrainians who are on
who
are gonna fight
how far do you go in supporting them can
russia at this point say well we can't
help you you have to get along you have
to somehow you have to be absorbed by uh
they kev you're going to be absorbed by
them and they're going to be
they're not going to give you autonomy
and you have to live with them
and there's going to be a price to pay
you could do that and you can also say
well we open our borders to don't ask
you can come into our country you can
leave and we will help you to to
resettle
and that's that would be a reasonable
approach so you take it to the next
stage as putin's thinking you take it to
the next stage you
you stall
it's harder for your people of course
there's pressure on putin from inside
his own government to say what are you
going to do i mean you can't do this
there's a lot of nationalists in russia
they would certainly bring he it would
be to his they'd say putin is weak and
that's the biggest rap you can ever give
a russian leader is you're weak you
can't get anything done
so there would have been some damage but
let's say he goes with that and he says
okay we know what the united states
intention is it's to
get rid of me
regime change and to get another yeltsin
in that's what they want and they will
go to any ends they will destroy ukraine
if necessary but they want regime change
in russia and then after they do that of
course they'll go after china but that's
the ultimate policy of the united states
this is a
country that has no compunctions about
going all the way
and it will use hypocrisy in all the
news propaganda in the world to get what
it wants this is the equivalent frankly
of
germany's uh goals in world war ii
uh world domination there's no question
in my mind but
we're going about it in our way as
opposed to hitler's way
so just to finish your thought where do
they go
what's stage two okay you let's say they
take ukraine takes back donbass
let's say people get killed in large
quantities
so we now to the next stage we're
finished with the minsk two agreements
that were never adhered to so what does
russia do they wait for the next
aggression
which is going to come in one form or
another
perhaps in georgia perhaps i don't know
what happened what the us is thinking
but they would have the us cannot say
uh russia is has done anything they have
not used violence to stop donbass from
belonging back to uh
ukraine right so
you're in a new setup now it's a whole
thing rearranges
now you have but you still have nuclear
weapons
and you still have russian
nuclear weapons and they're serious
weapons they're very well developed
crude but not as refined as the american
nuclear force but
powerful
that becomes another game then you open
another chess board and no one you still
haven't been condemned the sanctions
haven't been imposed that's a new it's a
new game
could he have done could have lived with
that that's the question i asked myself
so you see ultimately ukraine today as a
battleground for the proxy war between
russia and the united states the united
states would have then nato waged nato
eyes ukraine or
certainly put more weapons and you know
the united states has already done a lot
in ukraine with intelligence with
training
advisors
the uh the intelligence aspect of the
ukrainian army has been raised
enormously by the united states
contribution
you